hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar from
design
to implementation of tsar's cov2
diagnostic testing i am michelle ashton
of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by abbott scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics to learn more
please visit the sponsored by tab
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send questions will be
answered during the presentation
and also via email following this event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i now present today's speakers dr gavin
clardy
head of infectious disease research at
abbott diagnostics
dr frederick multi professor and vice
chair
laboratory medicine and medical director
of clinical laboratories and molecular
pathology
the medical university of south carolina
and dr james kirby the associate
professor of pathology
at harvard medical school and director
of the clinical microbiology laboratory
at beth israel's beginners medical for a
complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen our speakers
will now begin
their presentations
it's a real pleasure to be here today
and to have the opportunity to present
you know the design and development
concepts and implementation of our sars
kobe 2 diagnostic tests and
you know to to share uh this
presentation with dr nolte is also a
great pleasure
um so you know when i was given this
title uh of
a talk i decided to take the um
approach in developing the talk of just
putting you in the context of what we
were thinking
as this whole pandemic was unfolding
before us
and how we went about approaching the
diagnostic develop
the development of diagnostic tests
real quick let me walk through these
preliminary slides so the
mandatory disclaimer i'll leave that up
there for a second
and um obviously the title of the talk
is the design and development of stars
kobe to
uh diagnostic assays um
the learning objectives for for this
talk
uh will be talking a little bit about
the sars
kobe 2 in disease and the virus
a little bit about the molecular assay
design and development and also the
serological i'm going to focus
on the core lab assays uh
which we were more directly involved in
and not uh on the
um the rapid diagnostic point of care
tests that were more peripherally
involved in
uh the development of those guys so
um we're going to review the challenges
and uh
again of the nucleic acid test
development and
serological test development as well as
talk a little bit about the
um what we're learning about this virus
as we go along so then to get into the
talk
in earnest we'll we'll start off by
by looking at the sars kobe 2 virus and
the
disease associated with it and if we
look at this slide i think you
see um in it in context so it's not the
first
uh sars uh kovit uh chronovirus that
we've seen
obviously if we share this uh space with
the
normal uh beta coronaviruses these the
four strains that cause the common cold
but
the the first stars that came around in
2003 i think was
um killed about 700 or 800 people i
think the numbers
very very slightly but the mortality was
about 9.5 percent if we look at mers
uh the mortality was significantly
higher at 35 percent
and now we see uh the thesaurus kobe 2
of mortality is about seven percent and
that
uh the exact numbers above that are kind
of changed
daily and this uh date these numbers
were taken from the
the end of april so obviously things
have changed since then i think it's um
interesting that that the initial soros
kovi
did burn itself out mers still kind of
percolates a little bit and pops up
every now and again
but uh this uh current um outbreak of
stars kobe 2 has really become a
pandemic
um so the different um biology or
natural history of these viruses
are slightly different but what is
similar are the same
is the importance of the diagnostics so
the the importance of accurate and
timely diagnostics
in in identifying cases
that enable a rapid reaction both
chemically and from the public health
space
is critical i think on the right hand
side of this slide you see a
quote from the eu commission
so this uh illustration just shows a
normal
you know kind of uh immunological
response and biological response to to
an infection with
a normal virus what you would expect and
this uh
the reason for putting this slide in
here is to kind of present you with what
we were
thinking you know uh but we were very
much
conscious of the fact that we didn't
know this was a new virus and we
couldn't make any assumptions but
if we had to make an assumption here's a
starting point
and this led us to focus
initially on the most urgent clinical
need which was the identification of
people who are actively
infected in that acute phase that would
need to be done with a molecular test
with a direct marker
uh so a molecular test for the viral rna
um later we can maybe in another talk we
can talk about antigen
but uh and then following on that we
knew that
the the most pressing uh question would
be who's recovered who might be
able to go back uh you know to work or
those kind of key questions that people
have so we focused on the igg response
next but we also didn't want to mask
any information again we don't want to
be like you know a
term arrogant to think that we would
know everything about the
this virus so we can just lump all of
the serology together so
we separated out the igg and igm
development work streams
to make sure that we could have the most
granular information
about the patient in front of a
physician or the population
that a public health system was was
facing and so that'll bear out and
you'll see a little bit more about that
in the slides that follow
so our thinking um you know i think
which is bearing out uh was that if if
you look at this slide here it shows the
different
uh molecular serological markers and
what they might tell somebody so if
you've got a pcr
positive on its own it's most likely the
early acute
uh phase where the body has not mounted
an immune response and
at least enough to be detected and
moving into pcr
plus igm you're in that kind of middle
phase where normally pcr will start to
wane a little bit
and the igm will start to come up so
usually within the first week of symptom
onset first week or two
but your igg is still negative you can
have that spot where
igm is the only marker that's positive
and this
this might be in like the the um within
again the first week or so
there may be a day difference or two is
what we're seeing between igm and igg
coming up positive
but that might be an important thing to
note because if you didn't do that igm
both would be
uh negative and you might miss that case
and actually there are cases when all
three
are positive because we're finding that
igg is very a very sensitive marker that
comes up
uh quite early um and then there are
other permutations where pcr and igem
can be
uh positive if you're in the late stage
infection or maybe there's a miss by the
igm assay
or just again you get into the later
phases where serology
is is only positive in in the end igg
is the most durable marker uh that would
indicate for exposure and a past
infection
this slide here which we i pulled this
graphic from
a very short review paper scissor
mounted island jama it was
online at may 6th and it's an
interesting one
and certainly short paper so i'd
recommend it but what it shows
is how different this picture what's
important i think is how different this
picture is
when you compare it to what we expected
and the or could have expected in the
previous slide
you you'll note that the the rna
detectability definitely differs in the
course of infection
uh and by the sample type you know
whether it's a nasopharyngeal
nasal a throat uh sputum or whether it's
a stool
sample um whether or not the p you'll be
pcr positive
uh depends on that sample type and also
when this sample is taken
um also surprising well maybe not so
surprising because we saw a similar
thing with sar with the original sars
infections that
igg and igm come up at almost the same
time
uh there may be a day or two difference
we'll we'll talk about that a little
later but igm
does drop off more uh quickly than the
igg which remains positive
and an important note is that this virus
has only been in the human population
for a couple of months so
that's about that's all we can tell is
how long these these markers last
is in that limited time period
uh here we look at um you know the some
of the potential
uses for diagnostics and where they
could
fit in so initially
for diagnosis of the most critical one
is the molecular test the pcr test which
is
you know the gold standard for
identifying those patients who are
ill and actively viremic an antigen test
may have application there
that would definitely depend on the
format and the sensitivity and then
antibody
testing can have an application
i we may have a slide on that later but
just in terms of if you're in that spot
where the pcr may be waning and the um
the the serology may be becoming
positive it may have
the ability to pick up some incremental
uh positives there
there's a use for diagnostics in
discharge and you know this is
actively in debate uh exactly what that
should look like this current european
commission
uh guideline recommends an rna test so
negative
consecutive negative rna tests but you
could also
complement that with serology so if
you're you're negative with your rna but
and you have let's say an igg response
that might give you greater confidence
particularly if it's a robust igg
response in
releasing somebody and obviously for
serological surveys for epidemiology for
understanding
who has been infected really the the the
main
marker for that would be serology and
igg particularly because it's the most
durable marker so
you can see who has been infected and
how that is changing in a pop
at the population level over time
moving on uh to this slide i think
what's important you know we showed some
slides previously that
had been the normal virological response
what we're seeing in general with the
soros kovi too but this light really
illustrates that it's a personal journey
and it will
the from a serological perspective uh
change
uh person to person so you see four
different subjects here
uh some of them the the initial three
are
more normal in subject one becomes
positive after
you know several days of symptoms uh
subject to would become positive after
almost like
13 14 days uh takes that person to
become positive
subject three was positive right from
the initial time point
at day 12. but in the in subject four
where you've got an immunocomp an immune
compromised
uh patient as a transplant patient they
did mount an immune response but it was
later
and i think this is something to keep in
mind when you see
negative results let's say 14 days after
uh
symptom onset or more you really have to
look at
what's going on with that that
individual
and it's no i think in a specific test
is the silver bullet you've got to look
at the entire um
all the information you can and the
clinical picture in front of you to make
a diagnosis and understand what's going
on
on the right-hand panel here was pulled
from a from a paper
um i think it was tanadal but what they
looked at was uh the different
uh the different response in patients
who were critically ill and that was
defined as being on a
respirator or you know not critically
ill so they would have been
not on a respirator but would vary from
ambulatory
on up but what it showed was that the
the igg response was significantly
stronger in those patients who are
critically ill from those who are not i
think
you know more information will need to
to is coming out
on the significance of that kind of
robust response versus not i think
what we may be seeing is two different
kind of diseases one
is more biologically mediated and
another could be
immunologically mediated so you know uh
depending on what the immune system is
actually doing to the body and in a
given in a given patient
more on that now to
talk about the design and development of
the different assets that we were that
we we worked on
and kind of put you in the mind frame uh
you know the space that we were in
is what i'll attempt to do here and this
slide um just
speaks to the different things you've
got to do normally when you're
developing an assay
and i think many people on the the call
today
will be familiar with that you know the
bioinformatics the initial asset design
sample prep optimization the kind of uh
evaluation validation
that iterative cycles that go on and
just for reference when we're normally
building
a test for fda submission and the normal
ce mark
this takes years years of iterative
process and hard work to get this
done and to put things in context this
slide shows
how we accomplish this in weeks so
initially in the ide core where we sit
at abbott we were monitoring what was
going on in china and looking at
how things were developing uh with great
interest and concern
um the main thing we needed was a
sequence i think uh you know
this this was noted previously you know
we really
that is the starting point for building
a molecular test so i think it was
january 20th
if memory serves me and you have to
forgive me because
you know with everything being so
contents there's a slight fog
on the exact dates but i believe it was
uh january 20th
when the sequence became publicly
available and that was the day that we
um hit go and started building designing
the primers and probes
and getting those all ordered for
synthesis and that takes a bit of time
so we had a little lag
until we had all of the oligos and uh in
vitro transcripts and everything in
place
that was around february 14th so that
really was when things started in the
the wet lab development in earnest and
we had a prototype essay
available uh within days um
which actually you know i i the point i
make on
march 5th there was we developed this
with a certain enzyme formulation and
then we realized you know this would
need to be
done on scale and you know the and
it really hit us how much scale that
would be needed and how fast this would
need to be done
so we reformulated uh with a different
enzyme to
accommodate this kind of manufacturing i
want to tip my house
at this point to the guys in
manufacturing who've really you know had
to
step up to meet the demand uh and do it
in in
really quick time as well so we did that
reformulation and got ready
uh for eua verification studies by march
14th and then the
eua submission and again tip my hat to
to the fda
uh for making this channel open and for
working so
quickly to get this done in like a
24-hour period for turnaround and then
getting this launched
so this was a whirlwind as you can
imagine uh
also you know wanted to draw note the
fact that we were developing an asea on
really really limited sequence data
we had you know one two maybe three as
the days progressed
sequences so we were i don't want to say
flying by the seat of our pants but
because we
know what we're doing but it was
definitely a lot of sleepless nights as
this was going because things could have
gone sideways at any time
we tried our best to mitigate
all of this risk um by selecting
targets uh we took a dual target
approach um you know that really is kind
of getting to be the the gold standard
in pcr we wanted to build in some
redundancy in case we saw some
mismatches
we targeted nuclear capsid and rdrp
because uh we found that that is the
most highly conserved stretches is where
we found so
in addition to looking at the region
like nuclear capsid or drp can throw
those terms out it's really more
important to look at the sequence within
those
and um as we have the global
surveillance program ongoing for
you know many decades and this is our
stock in trade
we really dug into those sequences to
find the ones where we
thought uh would be the best targets
boats from uh conservation
now but into the future as much of a
crystal ball as we could try and and
work
to predict um so both of these targets
co-amplify in the test that was the
design and also to include the normal
armored pumpkin gene internal control as
we have in all our reti real-time assays
into this for additional um
additional quality control
so this slide um we look at the target
selection that we had versus some of the
others that were kind of out around
the same coming out around the same time
and um
we see that we were in rdrp so is
was charity in berlin as was the cdc
and we also had a target in n but i
think more importantly
than just uh saying we were in n and
rdrp
it's where we were uh in these c in
these uh regions
is the critical uh part then
needed to prove uh they are past the
test of time
we also looked at e and we have that as
a target region we can swap in or out if
we needed to but there was no
incremental benefit to that
so moving forward you know we didn't
just rest on those initial couple of
sequences
as you can imagine we were keenly
watching how this space was
evolving looking specifically at the
target regions where we were
and this slide shows some analysis that
was done
using genbank sequences looking for the
primary probe homology
looking at 13 more than 1300 full-length
genomes
and we found that 99.5 had a 100
identity
it was 99.5 of the sequences had 100
identity to our primers and probes there
were
a few as you always would expect there
will be that had uh some mismatches
there was a single mismatch
um in in uh six uh of
the samples uh to
our end target and one to or drp
uh there was no single sample
that had mismatches to both the targets
and none that would have any impact on
the assay performance again
looking at more sequence i think this
time from the gis aid database
looking at almost 15 000 samples again
we found 1.1 percent contained a single
mismatch this won't impact the test
um 0.4 had 2 and .007 so one out of the
almost fifteen thousand had four
mismatches
uh all in one of the the gene sequences
and um
so the this none of these um uh
mismatches or profiles would
impact the performance of the tests and
that is definitely very reassuring but
now that this uh virus is is with us
it is part of our global surveillance
program so we are actively looking
around the world um in in many many many
different countries
and generating sequence and looking at
the homology to our primers and probes
and the
performance of our tests so this is
firmly part of our global surveillance
program and our reality moving forward
and looking at some of the performance
data broadly that
has been done with this test it's very
gratifying to see that the clinical
correlation
across all sites is greater than 95
percent
and we haven't seen any cross reactivity
and uh we've confirmed that 100 copies
per ml
or greater um and by that probably means
less so
you know it could be 100 copies or less
as the limit of detection um
so we we've we've seen some uh like in
the university of washington where we've
got 93 percent
uh pickup at 25 copies um so that's
very reassuring i think if we look at
the
other sites here we're seeing a limit of
detection of 100 copies being reported
with almost 100 percent positive and
negative agreement
to the cdc assay
and the luminex assay you know the cdc
we have 100 positive
negative agreement and then with the
luminex assay there was uh one sample
where there was uh
uh not uh a difference in the negative
agreement so that's um
that's extremely reassuring uh both for
us in our test but also for the field
who if you're using the cdc or one of
these other tests i think it's
very valuable information
again looking at the the platforms you
know we developed this test for the
m2000
which is the old uh i would say over the
workhorse
that's around the world uh many
thousands of placements
but also this test was ported over onto
the alinity m
which is the i guess new
state-of-the-art platform you'd call it
um which has significant
uh benefits in terms of throughput uh
you know with about a thousand tests per
day
uh so that's that's a fantastic uh piece
of equipment
um so we reported that test over onto
this platform
if you see here um the data looking at
the positive and negative agreement
um you'll see uh 47 uh
positive samples we're also put with
m2000 were positive with the alinity and
there were two samples that were
negative with the
m2000 that were uh positive with the
limited em
and these one these samples had a cycle
number of about
40 almost 40 pretty much 41. so
that's at the very low end of the
dynamic range so we did see a couple of
incremental pickups with a link
so the positive agreement was 100 and
the negative predictive
value was 96.5 so again
quite comfortable with that with that
data
so in closing slide you know what's next
i think
uh you know it's important to know does
uh how much uh
virus is present in a person is that
important so via
rna quantitation could be significant if
rna is present in the blood
and how much could be an important um uh
question to answer
if we link that to clinical progress or
you know the clinical picture
from the serology perspective the key
question does antibody positivity
equal immunity does the how much
antibodies present does that influence
immunity or disease progression
clinical outcomes when vaccines are
developed
i think it's important uh that could be
the quantitation could become
extremely important if we look at
hepatitis and other
vaccines where you know we need to know
if the vaccine has elicited
a response that would confer immunity or
not therapeutic
interventions whether they be
monoclonals or other what impact will
that have
on the diagnostic test what role will
the diagnostic
tests play both in the development and
the utility of those
those therapeutic interventions and then
the ongoing epidemiology whether it be
surveys or surveillance
i think it's critically important and on
the right hand of this picture i think
it shows
i like it because it illustrates kind of
where we're coming from where we were
where we are where we're going to
you know from the reactive clinical
management
um you know at the outset of this
pandemic you know
under and that's still extremely
important as we still have people
coming in who are infected today but
expanding out to look at the population
level
looking for hot spots seeing how that's
changing uh
you know allocation of resources how
will diagnostics and the ability to
understand what this virus is doing as
the pandemic
evolves you know under and been able to
answer these questions and look at
things critically
i think will be important moving forward
so with that
i think that's the end of my talk i want
to thank again
for the opportunity to talk to you today
and present i'm very happy
to have been here and i hope this was an
informative talk for you
i just want to take a moment to thank
abbott molecular for asking me to
participate in this webinar my name's
frederick nolte
i'm at the medical university of south
carolina i'm vice chair for pathology
and laboratory medicine
the medical director for clinical labs
and what i'd like to share with
you folks today is our clinical
laboratory response to the covid19
pandemic and we'll go through
the standard disclaimers i won't read
these and the audience knows that
the support for this program is provided
by abbott i am presenting at the request
of abbott
and you can see all the disclaimers
regarding the use
of the the tests that i'm going to be
talking about from abbott
what i plan to do in the next 25 minutes
or so are
review the particular challenges and
successes that we have had in responding
to the increasing demand for diagnostic
testing for sars
ob2 um we're going to i'm going to spend
most of my time talking about nucleic
acid amplification tests for
detection of viral rna i do have one
slide at the end that touches on our
serological testing for the detection of
antibodies we have a
orthogonal algorithm that i think may be
of interest to the audience
and i've spent a lot of time describing
our experience with the abbott
m2000 uh sars coronavirus ii eua
assay and if you'll just permit me a
moment to
share a personal reflection um yeah this
is deja vu
all over again for me this is a
publication that
we put out and put it together in in
2003
but it is in response to the first sars
outbreak and you all remember that
in november of 2002 there was an
outbreak of atypical pneumonia
with a high fatality rate that emerged
in guadalup province and china
that became known as severe acute
respiratory syndrome
and the virus became known as the tsar's
coronavirus
it quickly spread to five continents and
by the time it burned itself out
in 2003 uh
who estimated there were 8 400 cases and
approximately 812
deaths so um why is this this relevant
this publication well
um at the time we didn't know what
um what the furosaurs outbreak was going
to look like
the u.s was largely largely spared any
big impact with that
but we were in a situation where
i first time in in my professional
career when a new virus emerged
immediately genomic information was
available and shared
molecular amplification assays detect
the virus were there
and we had no idea what the future
it was going to look like when it came
to sars
so we took it on ourselves to develop
and validate two laboratory developed
tests
we put them through their paces we we
had access to the appropriate reference
material
both commercial and from investigators
around the world
we were able to contrive samples uh we
were able to do the
the clinical validation piece the
analytical validation piece
and we did it very quickly and i want to
just keep this in mind that this is in
uh 2002 it's now 2020
and some of the challenges that we are
facing now
in response to the second sars
coronavirus
problem um weren't there in the early
2000s
so keep that in mind and also
i'm kicking myself a little bit i had
the foresight
in 2002 to be prepared before
the emergency or before we knew this
was going to be a public health threat i
was a little behind the curve
for this one the current one as were
many other laboratories
so what i'm going to do is try to tell a
story with the next few slides and take
you through the
you know one lab's experience the
evolution of molecular testing
capacities for sars covid ii here at
the medical university of south carolina
so early in the pandemic
all testing for persons under
investigation
was conducted at our public health and
cdc
laboratories and it was all coordinated
through our local
um uh epidemiologists that were
tasked here from the state health lab in
columbia
so as you might imagine the surge
capacity of the public health lab
and the cdc for testing was quickly
exceeded
our initial plan here at musc was to
offer
the only eua available at the time
uh the cdc test this is our first
issue with supply chain we purchased the
reagents the required instruments we got
the right
reference material to validate but we
couldn't get
the needed instrument to perform the
test the
abi 7500 fast ex we didn't have one
available in our laboratory
um we placed an order um the
we learned that the uh the instruments
are shipped from china
and so the boat was on the uh since the
instrument was on the slow
boat from china and took
several months took two months to arrive
uh we also realized while we were
waiting for it and with the increasing
demand
that the cdc assay really wasn't going
to provide us with the testing capacity
that we needed to support the demand
so our activities really ramped up here
around mid-march the 13th of march
musc has tremendous capabilities in the
telehealth arena
and we leverage that capability and
expertise to facilitate
evaluation and scheduling of local
patients and healthcare workers
were testing at a remote specimen
collection site
we made the decision that we didn't want
to bring these patients into the
emergency room or the
or the clinic because of the the risk of
transmission
in those environments so the testing
capacity
uh at the time we opened this of the
large national referral laboratories was
stressed with long turnaround times for
results
we had no local testing capacity because
we were waiting
for the delivery of the the abi
instrument from china
so we were forced to use a regional
commercial laboratory for
testing to support that collection site
but unfortunately they lack the
experience and capacity
to deal with the demand in a timely
fashion
so here's where the story gets
interesting
with respect to abbott so shortly after
we opened the
our first collection remote collection
site
i was approached by abbott scientific
affairs
asking me if i was interested in taking
a look at
their eua assay on the m2000
i responded very quickly and i said yes
um it's a number of reasons why it was a
a great
fit for us uh we have been um
an abbot m2000 user for over a decade we
had two instruments in our in our
laboratory
um abbott offered to to um
supply us with a third m2000
uh we the the speed by which
we got everything done
was unprecedented basically in
just over a week we went from
having the reagents to to having the
test validating
and bringing it online so we started
collecting specimens from patients in an
organized fashion
on the 13th of march and we were live
with the abbott m2000
on the 23rd uh this obviously we went
from
zero to about a thousand tests per day
capacity uh in a matter of a couple of
weeks
um we say our our turnaround time is in
the 24 to 48 hour window
um but our in reality the average
turnaround time for specimen receipt to
result
at um is typically 12 hours for us
our initial attempts to dilute genomic
rna
in universal transport media and viral
transport media resulted in poor and
inconsistent recovery
which was a bit of a surprise to me but
i guess i shouldn't have been
surprised by that however the same
dilutions
of the jomek rna made in saline showed
excellent recovery down to as low as 10
copies per mil
in our initial range finding experiments
for the
limit of detection this just shows that
the data for that dilution series and
the crossing uh numbers uh done in
in the quadruplicate and the mean
crossing numbers so the coefficient of
very variation of the
crossing numbers are range from 1.3 to
4.7
depending upon the concentration
so the next step uh was to look at some
of the other commercially
uh or the commercially available
material that was
there for us we used the exact
diagnostics and the serocare reference
material both of which have been
quantified by
digital droplet pcr
this just shows you that they all worked
in the in the m2000 assay it gives you
the
expected concentrations and the cycle
the crossing numbers for those
materials uh to confirm them
abbott's limited detection claim of 100
copies per mill we diluted one of the
serial killer
panel members and tested it 20 times at
a
nominal concentration of 100 copies per
mil all
20 were uh were detected with an average
crossing number of 26.7
uh the clinical verification of the
assay
um started out with the residual
clinical specimens that were collected
during the early phases of our
opening of a remote collection site so
they were
collected from march 12 through 17.
all of the specimens were sent to a
regional commercial reference lab for
testing by the cdc eua
assay we tested the specimens locally
with the biofire respiratory panel
as well we were also able to acquire
10 uh positive specimens from our
local public health laboratory that had
been tested by the cdc assay
and then we had finally received our
instrument
our fast dx instrument and since we had
all of the reagents on hand we
did a local lab comparison if you will
of the cdc eua assay performed
at musc with the abbott result so we did
that with 12 positive and 12
negative specimens so that can um
that comprises a clinical verification
data set or
specimens um so
we took 183 residual np samples
so we've been through these two points
the problem is when we looked at
our agreement with the regional referral
laboratory it was less than
ideal the positive present
agreement was only 75 percent there are
a small number of
positive specimens in this mix um
the the n1
n2 um cycle thresholds in the cdc
cdc test were for the false negatives
are listed here
and they're in the 30s uh low 30s to
high 30s
i'm not sure what to to make of that the
referral laboratory also reported three
inconclusive specimens
that they were unable to reproduce the
results
they tested negative by abbott so faced
with this
[Music]
we wanted to do a better job of looking
at the how well the abbott
assay compared to the cdc eu assay so
the 12 specimens that we received from
our local public health lab they were
randomly selected
and they the positive and negative
predictive values were
100
we did so looking at the
i'm sorry the the second bullet point or
the locally performed
test uh the first bullet point or what
we got from the public health lab in
both cases the positive predictive
agreement was a hundred percent
so overall if you put all three data
sets together we found a 91 percent
uh positive predictive agreement and 100
negative predictive agreement between
the results of the cdc and the abbott
test
and but we did see there with the
positive predictive agreement was
dependent uh upon where the test was
performed so
there is some interlaboratory variation
in in that
in terms of the how the results
compare to the eu to the cdc
eua assay
um the clinical verification also
included a comparison
uh to the the
respiratory virus panel results from
biofire
uh there were 168 specimens that were
concordant
negative for for covid uh for asarius
coronavirus 2 rna
we found other respiratory pathogens in
71 of those or 42 percent
and i'm not going to read all of the
different viruses we recovered but the
important thing is highlighted there
there were in this data set there were
18
uh specimens that were positive for
seasonal coronaviruses
uh which was actually um quite
interesting because that's more
um positives than we had for for uh
sars coronavirus two in this uh data set
and from this it allowed us to to you
know pretty robustly say that the abbott
assay was free of cross-reaction with
seasonal
coronaviruses as well as the other
common respiratory
pathogens so that's basically what we
did for the initial
analytical and clinical verification of
the
assay on the m2000 so this is kind of
the the end of the
the m2000 story and where we are
um today not that we're through with the
m2000 but this is
uh where the m2000s have gotten us to
date
so um since we went live
on the 23rd of march we have performed
almost 44 000 tests
from individuals throughout south
carolina and identified two thousand
patients
our current positivity rate taking all
comers is is at four point three six
percent
uh you can see in the panel over here
the steady growth in positive patients
per day
uh the test positivity since we're
serving this heat map over here
shows the um the different locations
that we
are serving and the number of positive
patients
uh in those zip codes if you will and
the darker red
indicates the higher uh percent positive
and you that percent positivity rate
from the patient populations we serve
ranges from a low of 2.85 percent
up to a high of almost 11 percent
um we are the second leading provider of
testing
uh behind labcorp in the state of south
carolina we're quite proud of that
ah finally yes uh light at the end of
the tunnel
um the abitalinity um
we are an early we have one of the early
instruments
uh it's been with us for a couple of
weeks now it's finally we're finally at
a point where we are
able to start the validation process
i'm going to share that limited data
with you in just a moment
but the reason that we're so excited
about it is it's basically the same
assay
that we've been running for the past
four months on the m2000
but the design of the instrument and the
way
the functionality and the throughput is
phenomenal so basically
we expect to get as many results out of
a single
linearity m instrument as we do out of
all three of our m2000s
the analysis time is much shorter the
random access
and the stun stat functionality will
help us with those demands for urgent
results
there are a lot of other good things
about it
but it it really is we're really quite
pleased to have it and hope to go live
with it
this friday actually as soon as we get
some of the i.t
issues squared away uh
just again this data i'm going to share
with you is very preliminary it's it's
the basis of
two of our verification runs that were
done just a couple of days ago
uh the first was to document the the
limit of detection
again using the accuplex uh verification
panel
um as a source of material uh we diluted
that down to the
following the nominal com concentrations
from 25 to
400 copies per mill you can see at the
100 copy per ml which is a stated limit
of detection
we hit that 95 mark we feel that we can
probably push that down to
250 copies per mil based on this
sort of range finding uh experiment so
we're going to give that a try
on a subsequent verification run
and here is the comparison of clinical
specimens run on the
uh the two instruments we have the avid
m2000 and the alinity m results we had
109 frozen
uh np swaps that were previously tested
on the m2000 we retested them on alinity
we found a positive predictive agreement
of 90 percent and a negative predictive
agreement of 98 we are currently
investigating a little deeper those
samples that were reported positive
on alinity i'm sorry on m2000 but
negative
on the alinity m uh you can see that the
uh the site the crossing numbers there
uh for those specimens range for were on
the high side
but not extremely high 27.8 to 31.4
and we did have one sample that tested
positive on the alinity m that was
negative
by abbott on the m2000 with a very
uh high crossing number of 40.99
so i know that was a lot um but i'm
going to leave you with
several final thoughts uh clinical
laboratory professionals are in the
vanguard of the response to the sars
pandemic providing accurate high quality
laboratory results aid in the diagnosis
treatment
and epidemiology
in this role we have encountered a new
number of regulatory
reimbursement supply chain logistical
and systems problems
that we have struggled to overcome in
order to fulfill our calling to provide
patient care
uh we are thankful for reliable industry
partners in this process
and i can't say enough about habit and
in
how they have supported our efforts uh
hopefully
our collective experience will be i mean
our experience like here at musc will be
of value to others
dealing with similar uh challenges and
the lessons we learn
as a community uh will make us better
able to deal with the next
pandemic thank you for your attention
hi my name is james kirby i'm the
medical director of clinical
microbiology at beth israel deaconess
medical center
and i wanted to share with you some
insights from
uh that we've obtained from sars kobe 2
testing using the abbott m2000 and
alinity
molecular diagnostic platforms this
speaker program
is sponsored by abbott and the
presentation will be
consistent with all applicable fda
requirements
so just uh this slide is a reminder of
emergency use authorization and what
that means
so i'll start out with our studies with
the
avid m2000 real time sars kobe 2
assay so that assay is a qualitative
emergency use authorization assay that
generates either positive or negative
results but sort of under the hood it
also provides
results which can be used to
understand quantitative performance
of the assays because real-time pcr
assays
as you know are inherently quantitative
and
during each amplification cycle
uh essentially to some approximation
um the number of uh amplicons is doubled
and um there's simultaneous
amplification and binding of a probe
in that probe fluorescent signal
therefore
increases uh geometrically during each
amplification
cycle and at some point
the um the signal from that fluorescence
crosses
a threshold and um at least in some
systems we call that threshold the cycle
threshold so it's the
amplification cycle number in which that
threshold for detection is reached and
the avid systems
uh use a slightly different um
thresholding measurement it's called the
fractional cycle number
or just cn or cycle number for short but
i'll
refer to that as a cycle threshold or
use those terms interchangeably the
uh the generation of the fractional
cycle numbers are actually very
interesting
and i'll refer to you i'll refer you to
the study by shane and clements
if you're interested in more details
about how that number is determined but
um it is it's a way to
um uh sort of avoid some of the uh
artifacts and uh fluorescent of
baselining okay but we don't need to
know those uh details
just that we get this very important uh
cycle number information
the m2000 assay and the
uh alinity assay that i'll tell you
about later
they're both dual target assays so
they're detecting
two targets within the sars cov2 virus
and um importantly the assays have a
robust limit of detection
and so um as i mentioned
um real-time pcr is inherently
quantitative and so you know
our goal was then to be able to take
this
um cycle threshold values
and convert that into a viral load and
see what that could tell us
about our testing results in our patient
population
so we determined that our limit of
detection
was um a hundred uh copies per
genome copies per mill um in
across our four different avid m2000
analyzers
and the ct value was approximately 26
and um you know as i mentioned uh
with pcr amplification if it's a 100
efficient you know that each cycle
number you're going to double
the number of amplicons so you go from 2
4 8 16 32
64 etc so you can approximate the viral
load
so we know that for example that
100 is our lod so you can use this
sort of simple formula 100 times 2
raised to the limit of the ct at the
limit of detection
minus the ct for any given assay
to come up with an approximate borrower
load so
and that sort of makes sense because if
your ct was 25
that means you're basically one
your resulting one
cycle earlier so you would expect that
your viral load would be twice as high
as your limit of detection
if you if you plug that into the formula
you get a viral load of 200
if you're one cycle later then you're
limited detection
you plug into the formula you get a a
bar load of 50.
well of course nothing in life is that
simple because
amplification efficiency is less than
100
and it decreases with cycle number
and you could these are
graphs of two
positive samples one with a very low ct
and one on the right with a very high
ct near the limit of detection and you
can see that there's
more sort of the slope is steeper
with a sample with a very high viral
load that gets detected earlier
and as you go through additional
amplification
signals to reach your threshold the
amplification becomes less efficient
by basically looking at
a lot of different curves like this
we're able to empirically establish a
formula
which we think fairly accurately
predicts the viral load
and from this from the ct value and
we've
sort of published
some of this data now in bio
archive if you're interested in more
detail so
i'll just leave it that we think that we
have a pretty good approximation of
viral load
and so then we looked at
our uh data from march 26 to may
2nd and you know that was sort of our
big surge
in the state of massachusetts so we did
27
000 tests we had 6 000 positives
4 700 unique patients and so we had two
questions so for a viral load to mean
something one of the questions was well
is it repeatable
if you swab someone's nose and
you get in twice in a row and you've got
a bar load of
100 one time and 100 billion a second
then fire loads would not be clinically
useful because we wouldn't really they
wouldn't necessarily mean anything
and the second question was can we learn
anything from the viral load
distribution
and would that help us understand how to
use our testing
so in fact the ct values and therefore
the viral loads
are reproducible between nasopharyngeal
swabs collected across
short time intervals so in our very
large data set we had a bunch of
patients
who had repeat collections either within
six hours or within 12 hours of each
other we don't know the reasons why
and then we plotted the ct value from
the first collection
versus the ct value of the second
collection you can see
that we have a nice sort of linear
relationship throughout the range of ct
values that we
um would obtain so it looks uh like
um uh those ct values are
repeatable in a clinical sense if you
sample patients
uh more than once so they're telling us
truly
about a status
of our patients
okay so then we um
decided to basically we converted our ct
values
for patient first positives and
we that's about 4 700 patients and
we basically bind those
those viral load results and
to show the fraction of cases in each
one half log 10 bin and so
our var loads range from very low up to
a billion
copies genome copies per ml and one of
the fascinating things was
that the distribution was fairly even
and so you see basically about the same
number a fraction of cases are
distributed
throughout the range of detection except
for
you know a drop off below 100 copies per
ml which is the limit of detection so
we considered that that was reflective
of the limit of detection of the assay
rather than
an actual uh change in distribution
so why this occurred occurs biologically
is not clear and perhaps as hand-waving
but
it may reflect the fact that viruses
replicating logarithmically somehow with
burst
sizes that spread out and affect
large numbers of cells sort of
consecutively
but in either case what that sort of
allowed us to do was then
plot sort of a cumulative
distribution so essentially what we're
plotting here
is at every point on the x-axis
is sort of the fraction of cases that
would be caught above
a certain uh viral load so
for example approximately 80 percent
of the results that we would expect
um would be caught with a viral load
um above uh 10 to the second genome
copies per ml
and so based upon sort of these results
what we what we did is we sort of
extrapolated with a red dotted line to
say
if we could detect consistently
basically a single uh virus
in a reaction what would that be
and um you know if if
we made that extrapolation and consider
that
you know ideal detection of a hundred
percent
then the abbott assay would detect about
90 percent of those patients so
the what i think is very important to
consider is
if you sort of look on the x-axis
and then consider the reported
lods of different assays so for example
the cdc assay has a limit of detection
of
a thousand or three thousand uh
depending upon the format that's
used the denmark eua has a little bit of
detection of
a thousand as reported in the literature
lab core about six
thousand in the sofia antigen test
above uh a million um if you
sort of uh do convert the units they
use based upon their reference material
um
that they use for their calibration into
uh genome copies per mill
so um you know these where you place
uh these numbers um there's probably
some
uh play but i think the important point
is
that as you increase your limit of
detection
you significantly affect the fraction of
cases that you detect
so for example with the sophia antigen
test
you might expect that you would miss
more than 50 percent
of the cases that you might detect with
the
sort of best-in-class uh pcr
methods one of the things that i should
mention in one of the problems in the
field and again this is
early and we're in a crisis situation is
there's no standard
uh there's sort of no reference standard
and
a lot of these for benchmarking your
assay so the limit of detection
um and these uh uh a reported limit of
detections have been
um uh uh determined using different
reference materials
so um you know i i would say that
you know take this graph as an
approximation
and there's clearly a case for some
universal standard
for benchmarking so that we as a
clinical community
can really understand the differences
between these assays
okay when all this happened it was a
chance to review sort of the anatomy of
the nasal passages
we have nasopharyngeal swabs which
proceed backwards into the you know
basically all the way back
um uh to the uh
nasopharynx and in red um we have nasal
swabs that
uh that sample more interiorly
and importantly the enter nasal passages
uh
are lined with squamous epithelium the
virus
replicates in ciliated respiratory
epithelium so there's
some theoretical concern that anterior
nasal swabs may not necessarily
sample the right place so we know that
nasopharyngeal swabs appear to have the
best sensitivity
and they clearly sample respiratory
epithelium
however they're difficult to collect you
need
trained collection staff and they're
uncomfortable we don't have people that
want to come back and volunteer
for repeat testing unless under duress
nasal swabs are easy to collect however
they may not fully sample the
respiratory epithelium
depending upon their depth and
there's difference in the literature
regarding performance of nasal swabs
so we
performed a multi-armed
clinical trial to compare the
performance of nasopharyngeal swabs
to nasal swabs in our patient population
and we basically shown in this graph
or the ct values the nasal swab and the
ct values of the nasopharyngeal swab
and anything that
which was negative we're reporting out
as a ct value in this graph of
37 and so you can see
that for um nasopharyngeal swabs with
ct values starting at about 21 and
especially going higher that we're
missing a lot of nasal swabs
and if we sort of plot this out
and this is a graph showing concordance
using a kappa statistic between
nasopharyngeal swabs and nasal swabs
these are done in parallel at the same
time in each patient
in that um you know above
a thousand cop genome copies per ml
there's
very good concordance but it rapidly
drops off
below a thousand copies per mil
so where does that leave us
and what's the use of nasopharyngeal
swabs
well first what's the explanation for
these observed differences
it's unclear it may be that
if you have a very exuberant infection
it spreads out more in the nasal
respiratory epithelium so it's easier
for
it to be sampled by nasal swabs but
that's
really unknown you know one question is
what makes a patient infectious and i
think that's what we're still trying to
understand
if you look in tissue culture and just
take for example the
bei resources cell culture control
material that many of us have been using
the ratio of genome copies to
the tissue culture infective dose
or 50 infective doses about 10 000 to 1.
so you have to have you know a lot of
genome copies to get
a single uh infected tissue culture cell
and this is similar to what's been
observed in patients
so for example in the study by wolfel it
all
suggests that the ability to culture
any virus from patients appears to occur
with viral loads greater than
a hundred thousand during the coven 19
recovery phase
so what we think
is that we should use the most sensitive
possible
collection technique nasopharyngeal
swabs in symptomatic patients
in patients who are being admitted to
hospitals and for contact tracing
but the nasal swab in terms of tradeoffs
may be an excellent thing to use in
larger screening
campaigns of asymptomatic individuals
and
locally we've been having a lot of
discussion about
for example weekly sampling in oncology
campuses and potentially in businesses
and the nasal swab would provide
an easy sampling technique
it would identify patients who are
infectious
and could then sort of reflex to further
contact tracing with
um uh or um resampling
in those in let's say a dorm room that's
infected with
a targeted nasopharyngeal swab
testing in the arms of our study we
compared dry swabs which were sent to
the lab and anterior nasal swabs and
deep nasal swabs
and they appeared to perform
equivalently giving us
multiple options okay so i've told you
about studies with the m2000
platform shown on the left hand side of
the screen
we're very excited to be one of the
first
uh adopters in the united states of the
alinity
m platform so
we wanted to get a feeling for how the
assay performed against the m2000
so shown here about 50 positive samples
comparing cycle numbers for the m2000
and the elite and they were highly
correlated and r
squared or 0.2 we see two samples which
had a lower uh cycle number for the
validity compared to the
sort of falling below that straight line
and
uh perhaps they were the amplification
in those samples were
um a little less less efficient on the
m2000
there was a shift in cycle number uh so
that
the cycle number for any given validity
uh assay was about 12 uh 12
ct or cn units higher that
you know raises no practical differences
and the assays were highly correlated
we also did a limited detection study
including testing at levels below the
claimed
limit of detection and using logistic
regression we estimate the limit of
detection is about
45 you know we didn't do a huge number
of replicates so
the black dotted lines to the
left and right of the red dotted line
are the 95 percent confidence intervals
so a limit of detection was excellent
um and just as one final note
of the utility to be of being able to
access
uh the cycle number or cycle threshold
values
were able to use those to support
a number of different uh initiatives um
in our coveted response
and i i'm sure that many of you
like we like us had
issues acquiring
certain basically supplies
needed for sampling patients so we were
went into high production to make
biotransport media
we made about uh three to four thousand
uh viral transport media tubes a day
for quite a long uh period and what we
would do is we would
for quality control since we had many
many
uh batches that we prepared every time
we had a new sort of
block we would spike a sample of that
lot
at 2x limit of detection with the
serocarry agent and determine the ct
value
and so these this is a plot of ct values
for different lots over a 30-day period
and so that's a levy channing's plot and
is expected
since we're 2x lod for the avid m2000
assay we had a ct mean of 25
and you know those pretty um uh
uh tight um uh amplification
uh showing us that you know each lot
there wasn't
um some sort of inhibitor that was
introduced
and so that we could you know use those
for patient testing
and um you know so that data has been
published
and um the first reference at the bottom
of
the bottom of the figure and then
we also worked with a number of
manufacturers
to help vet their 3d printed
swabs and one of the
questions that we had collectively was
whether they were using different types
of material to print their swabs and
you know it's really important to know
whether anything would leach
into a viral transport media and cause
pcr inhibition so we would
soak the swabs and viral transport media
overnight and then spike
the viral transport media 2x limited
detection
in um again look at ct values so we were
able to establish
whether uh there were inhibitors that
would affect
our uh testing so that was extremely
helpful
so in conclusion you know viral load
matters and especially the limit of
detection of your assays you really know
need to know what they are and
that will impact the percentage of
patients that you will detect
i think there's a good uh a case for a
universal standard that will allow
us to understand how different assays uh
compare
um and you know uh it's hard for one
site to
uh bring in all the assays and compare
them with the same material so a
reference standard would be really
helpful there's uh i think clearly role
for both nasal and nasopharyngeal swabs
depending upon the sensitivity
needed and i think nasal swabs will you
know find their use in supporting
screening of asymptomatic patients
the um abbott assays had robust
reproducibility
which uh supported quality control and
quality assurance
initiatives in our response and the
sample to answer a linear dm platform
uh shows a low limit of detection
and a high degree of uh agreement with
m2000
and it's we can already see that sort of
sample to answer
and rapid turnaround time has been very
helpful
in our helping our hospital
system i'd like to acknowledge a lot of
people
annie chang our molecular supervisor
tammy galloway our molecular
laboratory manager we have an amazing
group of clinical laboratory
scientists and a lot of
volunteers from our research division
and elsewhere that have been keeping our
clinical lab and
pre-analytics and post analytics going
so i can't thank them enough
uh romney are now in the cls6 covid
research team that have helped with a
lot of the studies that i
i told you about uh stefan riedel
associate micro director ryan pena
um uh the molecular uh clia
a holder and um hla director in our
hospital system our pathology
administration
and avid molecular and with that i will
close and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you so much
thank you all for your informative
presentations we would also like to
thank
labyrinth and our sponsor abbott
scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics for underwriting
today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
lab routes will alert you via email when
this webinar is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye